AND GETTING YOUR PIECES
TOGETHER.
I KNOW IT'S ANOTHER YEAR WHERE
THEY'RE NOT MAKING THE CLEAN, S
IN A ROW WITH BAD STARTS.
BACK IN FRONT.
AND SEVERSON PUT
>> Gord:
BACK FOR CHABOT. BATHERSON.
NORRIS ALL DED UP ON THE YEAR A
BRADY TKACHUK, MY GOODNESS.
COMES OFF, WIN T OUTSIDE OF THE
THE PUCK BATHERSON.
CENTERING PASS.
G
SENATORS POWER PLAY.
NORRIS AND THE THREAT OF HIM.
PRESS IF HE WILL PLAY IN THE
WORLD CHAMPIONSHIPS,
JUST DRIFTED IN. .
>> Gord: ZACHA.
SHOOTS.
IT.
WALSH.hael: OH, RIGHT.
AND WALSH IS MOVING.
HE'S GOTE NOW WITH TKACHUK
MOVE IN.
CENTRE HIM PICK THIS OFF.
LOOK WHAT HE'S BRATT.
JESPER BRATT BACK FOR SEVERSON.
BACK FOR BRATT.
AS HAMONIC IS DRAWN OUT.
OH, YEAH.
POSSIBLE A
TKACHUK HITS WIDE TO NORRIS.
TEES BACK TO  OR SHARANGOVICH.
SEVERSON, GREAT.BRARTSON.